good morning believe nation today's
message is dare to fail over to you
aaron sorkin you'll meet a lot of people
who to put it simply don't know what
they're talking about in 1970s CB s
executive famously said that there were
four things we would never ever see on
television a divorced person a Jewish
person a person living in New York City
and a man with a mustache by 1980 every
show on television was about a drove
horse Jew lives in New York City and
goes on a blind date with Tom Selleck
develop your own compass and trust it
take risks dare to fail remember the
first person through the wall always
gets her they're gonna fall down but the
world doesn't care how many times you
fall down as long as it's one fewer than
the number of times you get back up so
failure is one of the most common themes
that I come across on the channel and if
you look at one side the people who are
so afraid to fail and then on the second
side the people who who are successful
have failed so many times any successful
person you look up to anybody in any
field got thereby failing and failing
and failing and failing they've had a
few successes and way more failures
there's a couple of things your own
feeling that I want to address thanks to
this video the first is the message of
this video is dare to fail I don't think
you have to be that dairy to fail I
don't think you have to go out and do
some huge big thing and you know
mortgage your house and go all-in on
this idea that has to work and it's a
massive project that's one option I
think you can fail way smaller and I
think you should I think as soon as you
get an idea that you want to try
something that you owe it to yourself to
go out and try and bail as small as
possible just to see
like you want to start a YouTube channel
maybe that's one of your goals or
aspirations I want to start a YouTube
channel great what's involved in
certainly YouTube channel and suddenly
you're gonna say well I need a camera
and I need light and I need a microphone
and I need to do research I need I need
to learn editing skills or you the
higher editor and you start adding up
all these things that all they're doing
is putting roadblocks in front of you
that prevent you from doing anything and
instead of going big with it I'd say go
small just start because so many people
will start it will try it like that you
spent all this money buying all the gear
doing all this stuff and then you do a
couple and you don't like it how many
things have you've gone and tried and
you didn't enjoy it
or maybe you enjoyed it once but it's
not gonna be the thing that you want to
do for the rest of your life for at
least the next couple years and that
happens to so many people I'm gonna
invest all this money into all this gear
to make great videos and then you make
two and you stop because it's not what
you want to do and you're stuck with all
this gear and so when you have this idea
of something that you want to do just
start start with no money with no
connections with no resources just start
if you want to start a YouTube channel
then you know that you have a phone to
do it and if you don't have a phone then
one of your friends has a phone and you
can borrow from them and make your first
video the video quality is good enough
the audio quality is good enough you can
go outside and get some decent light and
you are good make that video and start
and if it works and you love it and you
just you want to eat it up you want to
do more great make another one and make
another one in the make another one you
can make a business case around it
amazing buy a proper camera hire an
editor get lighting get a microphone
work your way up or you do the first one
and you hate it and you realize you
never want to do it again perfect get
the knowledge because otherwise you have
all these dreams that just sit in your
head I wish I could do this I wish I
could do this and all these things just
sit up as wishes that never result in
anything go out and do and fail on a
small scale it does not have to be some
big bold daring dream or goal and even
if it is
shunk it down to what I can do today to
get started on that whatever huge big
dream ambition school you have amazing I
love it
what's the first small step that you can
do to take action towards it the other
thing about failure that I need to
address is people see it as some final
thing that because you failed because
the first thing didn't work out then
that's it
where failure is not a bad thing failure
is just feedback on how not to do
something failure just means you can get
up and do something better the next time
if I go back on my youtube channel I
look at my first video it wasn't very
good right it's not something that I am
insanely proud of apart from having the
courage I used to go and do it but
that's not something I watch over and
over again and like man look at this
amazing video the video was not very
good but it also wasn't a failure just
because it didn't get a hundred thousand
hour million views it wasn't a failure
it was the best effort that I could have
done at that point and then I made
another video in another video in
another video and you know thirty six
hundred videos later it's getting better
and hopefully tomorrow's video is better
than today's and tomorrow's Evan is more
impactful than today's and it's an
ongoing process of growth the only
failure is if I stopped the only failure
is if you quit if there's something that
you really want to do and you try it the
first time and you suck at it first
expect to suck because it's the first
time you're doing anything you're not
gonna be great at it from the start
but it's only a real failures if you
have this dream and your first attempt
doesn't work and then you stop
that's failure otherwise it was just an
attempt and tomorrow you try again and
the next day try again and every day you
get a little bit better and a little bit
closer to your goal
that's how success works so the question
today is I'm curious how do you define
failure what does it mean to you I'm
curious leave in the comments I'm gonna
join the discussion I also want to give
a quick shout out to Adam rust Adam
thank you so much you're picking up a
copy of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to me and I
hope you enjoyed the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot
they believe nation if you want a little
bit more inspiration and motivation
around failure here are some bonus clips
that I hope well
after finishing my adventures of Dark
Knight I decided we need to go in two
completely different direction
[Music]
while I think of the notes for the tune
I try to think of what's the sonic world
we're going to pour this tune into and
that's what we're doing experimenting
that's what you're supposed to do you're
not supposed to stand still you don't
really want to be observed and your
greatest failures and you have to invite
failure if you want to go an experiment
and if you have to try to do something
original we have to have a certain
amount of privacy to have the courage to
fail I listen to the people who were
successful in selling that product I
would learn new things from different
ones and new approaches and that's very
you must be a constant student a lot of
people are afraid to try anything new
because they are afraid that they will
be embarrassed until they get good at it
well one of my favorite sayings is you
know the most important thing you can do
is to understand that anything worth
doing is worth doing poorly until you
can learn to do it well my first few
sales calls were pathetic but I knew it
was worth doing so after it's you know
my first few speeches were this ester
but I believed that I could develop into
that so I kept at it until I could do it
effectively and all skills are exactly
the same way no running back that sets
the records ever we set a record the
first time he picked up a football and
you can go right down the line with that
so if it's worth doing and you believe
in it go ahead and fail and the more
times you fail the closer you get into
success because you should be learning
on every simple thing that you do what
has been the best advice you received
from your teacher or professor
oh I've gotten a lot of great advice
from teachers mentors professors
throughout the year so first of all you
got to be open to taking some risks and
not being afraid to fail failure is the
key to success so when you get to
college you got to raise your hand you
have to
be engaged don't be the kid thinking oh
I shouldn't be here and maybe I'm not
smart enough and maybe you know no you
are more than capable of going to
college being successful and going on
and doing whatever you want in life
I sit here because I am you all there is
no difference between me and you
working-class kid growing up on the
south side of Chicago
growing up with doubts and fears just
like all of you all do I know exactly
how you all are feeling and kids out
there who were thinking maybe I'm not
ready maybe I'm not good enough maybe I
can't afford it but what teachers and
mentors have told me is that yes you can
and you must so get in there and be bold
with your intelligence raise your hand
get support when you need it and know
that we all got here because somebody
helped us